what is happening there reject nation
greg and john here today happy new
year's eve the end of 2021 it has been a
bizarre past couple years
needless to say it's been very very very
strange and yet uh i wanted to hop on
here hey just to say thank you as usual
but this is a little bit more than usual
because this year has easily been our
most successful that we've ever had and
that is due to you guys just watching
our [ __ ] so i really
really appreciate
the support like sincerely it's it's
pretty crazy to be like wow you know
this this has still been growing
steadily it's easily been the best year
we've ever had like special shout out to
all our patrons as well it's a parajects
because you guys came in our lives when
the channel was going through a
transition okay here's here's the short
version of what's going to happen with
the real rejects right i don't know how
many you guys have actually been here
since the beginning some people say that
but i'm like have you really
proven it yeah so this quiz obviously
when the channel started taking off it's
when we started doing like you know
reaction stuff and there's like the time
of you know i was like mainly just me
bringing on a bunch of guests all the
time covering like a wide range of
whatever you know it's called like the
real rejects moves all kinds of things
and then uh it was some portion a few
years into it when it was like i want to
kind of streamline this a little bit
more kind of bring it back to the the
original plan which was hey john you
want to like give this a round two and
actually partner up yeah drop and dish
about movies yeah yeah i know a lot of
you guys came in uh at the point when
you know you saw that it was greg and
john very consistent here together and
now it's like definitely us remember the
times we were like you come on once in a
while people like what is it john of his
own channel oh yeah and then now now
we're here
now we're here yeah the home of john
this is the home of john now yeah we're
here you've replaced all the women who
used to come on i am all the women all
the women are gone it's only john
anderson sometimes
sometimes aaron alexander's
sometimes andrew gordon we got tara we
got sarah we'll burn back some female
guests once in a while some lady guess
bring that presence by but with the way
the channel is over that way the way the
channel has shaped up into obviously
we're a little bit more streamlined
about the kind of content that we
produce and i'm just so grateful for you
guys really making all the work pay off
you know this line of work as like
time-consuming as it can be and as
involved as gonna be with taking in
feedback from people we get a lot of
positive feedback and then you deal with
the occasional negative feedback
you know i really do feel like we are
constantly trying to grow or improve
ourselves in some way so while when it
started to really grow was they're doing
reactions i really feel like that if you
go back a few years ago you will see
there's an improvement in quality oh
yeah and i appreciate all you guys have
stuck around all this time to to watch
us get inch by inch better
i know there's still a lot of progress
to do but i appreciate that you guys
stick around for the progress oh yeah
you guys have helped us find our niche
and you've also been super consistent in
a time of complete lack of consistency
in life because this this what we do is
we're so fortunate to be doing this like
to to not be doing just a regular type
of job to be able to to to produce
videos on youtube and make our living
off of this it's insane it's still
insane and i do not take that for for
granted you know like a lot of times we
might show up here looking tired and i
even read a comment the other day that
the person deleted right away which is
bizarre so i was like replied
who did talk about like you guys talk a
lot about being tired but you guys are
in a good position and i did take that
to heart actually because i was like
yeah you know we sometimes we're tired
but i'd rather be tired doing this than
anything else yeah yeah you know
sometimes it is just a lot of assembly
and a lot of behind-the-scenes work and
that's just part of the machine of
youtube and i think if you look at any
channel you'll find people experiencing
that you know at some point or another
but yeah i mean we do our best to bring
the best energy and you guys are great
at reciprocating that whether it's here
on youtube or over on patreon you guys
have such enthusiasm for all the stuff
that we love to talk about and that back
and forth that you know sharing of that
energy is really special and really kind
of brings all this together at the end
of the day and it's helped us you know
find or at least get closer to our niche
you know where we work the best here
yeah so it's been like a total blast and
and i remember like for a few years
actually it was like people wouldn't
even stick around for for the commentary
side reactions and and now more you guys
especially looking at the analytics on
like watch time
or even some videos that what's not
about like you're watching us watch
something yeah more you guys stick
around for the commentary than before
and i and i really appreciate that
because that's normally where we have
the most fun and more more of the
editing goes into play so i really
really do appreciate that even though
this video is unedited lies just wanted
to keep it raw and they watch us stumble
over our words man how do i be sincere
how do i be there
we're on youtube we got who we got to
communicate this in a way what's up guys
we're youtube personalities keep
watching for the whole video yeah i want
you to ring that bell
smash that like button come on over to
patreon
anyway that's the youtube voice right
but that's not but thank you guys for
sticking around for the progress and uh
you know we got
you know
people are always like we got big plans
i don't really have like big plans for
that so i just gotta go with the flow
more of the thing and see what we can do
to kind of mix things up once in a while
and we'll do our absolute best to keep
trying to just make sure that we're you
know engaged in what we're doing and
having fun what we're doing because
ultimately that's what matters most is
that we're to make the best videos
possible we got to be having fun and you
guys help us have a lot of fun so thank
you because it is easy to lose sight of
perspective on you get so caught up in
what you're doing in your own little
bubble
that you it's sometimes when i step out
of it and i go it's pretty freaking
awesome that we get to do what we do so
thank you for helping us live such an
awesome life
ultimately
thank you guys uh much love to every
single one of you let us know in the
comments what your 2022 plans are
peace out reject nation
subscribe to get accepted to the reject
nation that's going to be that i'm
looking for a closer here yeah subscribe
to get accepted into the reject nation
subscribe to get accepted into the tribe
that's the truth first because it rhymes
it rhymes with subscribe yeah it's
nothing it should probably be more
specifically tuned to like you know the
brand next get of the reject the real
reason if you feel rejected come get
accepted
that's better it's a working process
we'll figure it out that's the big place
to give to you guys
[Music]